juan pablo y juan carlos son pareja
desde 2016 desde hace tres años viven
juntos en santiago pero no se pueden
casar porque el estado todavía no
reconoce el matrimonio igualitario
sin matrimonio sin la posibilidad de
casarnos no somos iguales en dignidad y
derechos
derecho solamente tengo las mismas
obligaciones maría cecilia y marcela
están en una situación es similar
firmaron el acuerdo de unión civil en
2018 un proceso aprobado en 2015 que
reconoce casi todos los derechos del
matrimonio heterosexual excepto la
adopción y los derechos de afiliación de
los niños con una hija la pareja no se
siente respaldada por la ley si algo le
sucede a la madre biológica a marcela y
tienen puesta la esperanza en el senado
en otra línea la cámara de diputados
rechazó la despenalización del aborto
hasta las 14 semanas con 62 votos en
contra frente a los 65 a favor algo que
deja la causa archivada a pesar de las
multitudinarias manifestaciones
feministas
y ese derecho en los últimos años al
fascismo no al fascismo no retrocedamos
a los años 70 73
porque
hoy en día tenemos un poco más de
derecho tanto el matrimonio igualitario
como el aborto marcaron la campaña de
las elecciones en chile en la que el
ultraderechista josé antonio kast que
está abiertamente en contra se impuso el
izquierdista gabriel boric quien es
diputado actualmente no participó en la
votación todos los grandes partidos de
la oposición chilena respaldaron al
candidato boric de cara a la segunda
vuelta presidencial del próximo 19 de
diciembre